well my my my it's almost Christmas so
you might as well see what happened in
November I'm not gonna take too much of
your time up with the intro but as
always n once again thank you very much
for watching these journal entries I
just I make them for you and me I make
them for us and it's fun to edit and go
back it's daunting to edit but every
time I do edit I'm glad to have done it
because it's neat to kind of mentally
relive the month for myself so hopefully
it's enjoyable for you too so here we go
let's get right into it transition yes
with a puppy now she's casting spells of
the day after Halloween 50% off oh yeah
these are good I don't care what it says
I remember it being good anyway [ __ ] my
pellets kind of expanded since I was 10
it's 4:30 in the morning and I've been
playing more Final Fantasy 10 and I can
ever admit to you but I guess Benioff
and Weiss no longer doing a Star Wars
movie see Star Wars movie that they
killed Game of Thrones for so Game of
Thrones died for nothing
I've been fighting this guy for 30
minutes by probably not that long but
it's definitely a two steps forward one
step back kind of fight this is one of
the most important scenes in any
Terminator movie just the raw power on
display here this thing's unstoppable
and it would never start a [ __ ]
family on tickles Animas not even human
anymore ready blam
and yeah I'm totally farming for gear oh
yeah if you know the farm spot yeah you
know why that's great you know why
that's delicious I love the game I hate
the minigames in this game holy [ __ ]
iPad I so I guess I just have to record
it and I'll pass it lobbying to
demonstrate it's a lot like the first
shitty one with balls only there are
birds and the balls explode
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
well I got my 90s douche hair going on
they got me 21 Jump Street
but I guess Terminator dark fate bombed
in the box office we're talking ebadi
we're talking twenty nine million
dollars opening weekend badly which
that's it's the natural course of things
right that's how it's supposed to happen
people didn't like what they heard about
the new Terminator movie so they spoke
at their wallets and they didn't watch
it soon people ask why no therapy
sessions actually into therapy yesterday
I just didn't make a an entry on it
this is scented gypsy drink of water
door dips we'll wait
but I've seen people asked like what why
no you're still going to serve it yeah I
totally do we got to the point where
it's like alright let's just go once a
month or so and if there's someone who
cancels an appointment with her show
she'll let me know like have an opening
if you want to come so and I usually
take that opportunity and then sleep in
so I had so I went yesterday it was
really good we actually deconstructed it
was it's kind of amazing what happens it
there but it's not always magic
sometimes you're sitting around like
everything's kind of fine um but
yesterday there's just kind of you know
personality habitual things your
personality traits that people have we
kind of traced it back to like oh yeah
you're teenagers totally forms that
what's like wow we just made bricks out
of clay and now I'm gonna do my Ford
versus Ferrari review this is impossible
whoever created this stupid mini game
was drunk high and evil I'm pretty sure
this [ __ ] joke about race is changing
me as a person I'm gonna check something
actually hold on we're gonna check the
old save file to see if I ever did it
back in the day oh my god I did it back
when 2002 me would be so disappointed in
2019 me alright I decided to give it one
more shot and here it is we're gonna
find out together alright this is the
score I gotta let that one go that's
taking me to dark places I'm getting
that frustrated it's not healthy plus
the amount of time I spent doing that I
could have done what of a million other
things so maybe I'll come back to it
later 0.01 seconds off it hurts but
whatever let's go to bed
[ __ ] danger you ready for bed it's only
5:00 a.m. on today's agenda brushing up
on the shining before i watch dr. sleep
people have asked me where my doctor
sleep review is I think everybody else
has reviewed it video of you I totally
forgot to RSVP to the screening invites
though
look it happens sometimes so for some
reason gypsy gets in these moods where
she lays there and tongues just I was
like a little tab a little tongue tab
she just got back from seeing dr. sleep
really enjoyed it just picked up death
stranding looking forward to it so I'm
gonna do a video with dr. sleep I'm
gonna start death stranding and that's
Friday
I watched Terminator 2 Judgment Day last
night the movies a masterpiece a
complete epic masterpiece and it ends it
too though they could have brought John
Connor in to Terminator dark fate as the
protector cuz like I said in my video he
could have been like I was raised for a
war that didn't happen like how do you
have a childhood like that and go on to
live a normal life I mentioned it's very
difficult so all I knew was fighting all
he knew was a pending war so he could
have been like it I'll protect you from
this new shitty future that doesn't
really have to do with me but help you
out in a way I'll I'll help you and then
I'll find I'll find myself
I'll find purpose I would have been fine
with that but they just kill them so my
mom's fridge sprung a leak you know a
water leak from the water line running
to the fridge so she asked if I can come
to her place wait for the repair guy
because she works today so here I am
she has Christmas music playing I don't
know if you can hear it we got ourselves
some Charlie Brown Christmas playing so
yeah radio stations already playing
Christmas music so here I sit with my
trusty PSVita some blood-stained curse
of the moon and wait for repair guy and
controller speaker down because the
sound of that [ __ ] baby crying when I
get attacked in death stranding I'm
gonna get a vasectomy so Seahawks won
today which is always a couple of people
who shoot off fireworks local ish like
it's the 4th of July or something wrong
on this particular day they're really
lighting off some heavy m80 [ __ ]
now [ __ ] danger freaking out what the
[ __ ] is happening Who am I
identity crisis ah so I'm about to film
a video in the Sonic the Hedgehog
trailer which looks 100 times better
than the first trailer so you knows
we're talking about props to them let's
talk about Sonic and his new eyes and
teeth okay so I use a zoom h4n to record
my audio and it broke so I need to get
another one
what happened was the SD card got stuck
inside and so I had to take a needle
nose pliers and get it out and I broke
it so I am going to go to Best Buy
they're open till 9:00 but I have to
edit and upload this video so I got to
edit like the wind I'm almost like this
I wish it was more tech-savvy probably
behoove me to be text like be able to
fix electronics my dad can do that
either Wiz at it I am NOT that person I
can talk on the internet though got it
what's upstairs for like a second gypsy
stop sit good place so I left the room
for a second he knows I'm calling him
out and I'm like oh wait I forgot
something and I come back in and danger
it is on my chair my chair for the table
where I edit my videos where I keep the
SD card I'm pretty sure we found the
guilty party of who ate the SD card in
September yeah I know I just blasted all
over the internet danger I'm sorry now
say no gypsies like I didn't do [ __ ] so
the screening to a beautiful day in the
neighborhood they're doing a food drive
so let's get some food can't go wrong
with the college dorm room luxury top
ramen minestrone is classic got some
old fashioned vegetables some cream of
potato in there to everyone else okay
ten for ten come on rice
I like people too much to give them spam
oh here we go some fruits and veggies
all right some apple cider mean it's
unsweetened but you know what if someone
needs unsweetened applesauce and I'm
also not going to do a video on
Charlie's Angels the screening was today
and then Sonic the Hedgehog trailer I
was like or I could not fight Seattle
traffic to go who's screening for a
movie I don't really care about and talk
about the Sonic the Hedgehog trailer
when I talked about the first trailer
issued about how he looked so it's kind
of like you know it's part of a sock
okay so setting up my zoom I totally
forgot that you have to set the phantom
power settings and switch it to mono
mode because I only have it hooked into
one so it records one channel as both
channels right and left channel like
it's well they forgot about it so did
this whole thing and I'm like I can't
hear jack [ __ ] and yeah there are some
helpful YouTube videos out there to
remind me of things I forgot about
because I haven't had to do it in years
I'm not gonna lie I am really worried
that I'm gonna sleep in tomorrow for the
frozen to screening also that is not a
bug it's a little screw or a picture
used to be yeah I'm one of those people
who owns three different versions of
Terminator 2 you got Terminator 2 on
blu-ray terminator to the Skynet Edition
on blu-ray and Terminator 2 on 4k
there's a reason for that
there's a reason for like initially I
actually had these this was my blu-ray
and then I got the 4k now the 4k has a
lot of a DNR some digital noise
reduction it has a lot of it actually
throughout the movie which makes it look
really clean and clear in some scenes so
some of the detail in the faces are
really washed out in other scenes in the
Skynet edition and the 4k have some of
the same filters the color filters used
that were not in the original version so
actually just about this I had to kind
of hunt it down a bit which is a blu-ray
version that said to be more Act
to the original I guess we'll call it
the VHS version that we all had whatever
version you want my god I actually have
this one as well I guess I'll put it
down here
it's the steelbook case I got it
thinking it was that version because on
Amazon it showed that version they sent
me this version which is the Skynet
version so I might keep it it should
send it back so it was seven bucks but
it's a pretty cool steelbook case so I
might keep it in which case I'll have
four Terminator 2 movies in my house
four discs why not there's only one real
reason I would do a terminator to break
down at 3:00 in the morning that's
because I'm not tired worried at this
point I need to get up early in the
morning for the frozen to screening and
I feel like I'm just gonna sleep in like
I've said all right I'm gonna go to bed
and I'm gonna try to sleep and I imagine
the more I try to sleep the more I'm not
gonna sleep is what it is we'll see how
it is in the morning I said I was gonna
sleep in and I slept in self-fulfilling
prophecy probably world's full of
self-fulfilling prophecies but I wanna
do videos on mandalorian episodes it
seems like a cool show and a good idea
just arrived to my screening of a
beautiful day in the neighborhood and I
got a screening invite for a second
screening of frozen that barely ever
happens but it's from Monday and it's
that night so I'm gonna sleep in for
that one it's like the universe was like
you know what here so I appreciate that
thanks universe other net a goal of food
here for the food drive Tom Hanks
overseeing everything you want to know
how scatterbrain my mind is I'm editing
my won't you be my neighbor review and I
just realized something I swear this
just hit me t1000 gun clips his spare
Clips right there supposed to be a
little more in the front
more like that I think that's good right
that my mom's eating dinner and I
realized gypsy in danger built like
tardigrades gypsies offended so I saw
the pilot episode of the Mandalorian and
I liked it I just wish I could binge it
so i guess i'll watch it week to week
and then binge it when it's all out so
our editing my Mandalorian video because
you know I edit at like midnight it's
3:42 in the morning right now because my
Internet's out and I don't know why I
mean I need to be on the internet to get
the images that I put in refuse and
whatnot so I'm kind of at a standstill
otherwise you'd have one of those 3 a.m.
uploads as usual I'm watching gargoyles
which is the real reason to get Disney
plus if you're gonna get it I would be
real with you I always thought Damona
was hot oh is that still do so is Angela
she's hot too so Joker crossed a billion
dollars congratulations to Joe Carr than
that Joker does get the last laugh oh
[ __ ]
I mean I know what I'm supposed to do
I'm supposed to go here God took a break
from Jedi fallen order last night
wouldn't visited my brother and his
family it was nice seeing them it was
really good seeing them so I lick my
wounds I go to bed I wake up today we
get back at it with Jedi fallen order
I'm gonna go to that trooper and I'm
gonna take those [ __ ] sticks of his and
shove him up every orifice he has and
where there's not an orifice I'll create
one with the lightsaber because that's
how we do it we not being Jedi no we're
gamers and that's how we do it I'm
stopped at a gas station so I'm not
driving but all my friends hate this
song this song is weirdly classic to me
eyes are gonna talk low cuz my voice
carries quietly quiet in here but even
Zack Snyder and David Ayer like they're
tweeting about the Snyder cut like Zack
Snyder tweeted with the hashtag released
the Snyder cut this gotta be something
to them but that's the guy the Snyder
cuts named after the director of
come on so the show's called kings of
pain and there's two guys just go around
the world and get stung and bit by
animals and creatures and of course it
hurts it's supposed to hurt it's called
kings of pain the whole shows them just
experiencing pain and it's morbidly
Intertek I'm not gonna subject you to
this sorry I've been binging gargoyles
for hours Mandalorian and I've enjoyed
it but the number one reason to get
Disney Plus right now come on it's
gargoyles but I've also been looking
into the Snider cut ever since ever
since that journal entry where I was
like way they're all tweeting about the
Snider cut the actors are and then zack
snyder and so you have the actors
tweeting release the snyder cut you have
zack snyder the director saying yes it
exists you have Jason Momoa saying he
has seen it I mean I got to take them at
their word they would know more than any
tweeters or youtubers out there or this
is just the meanest four and a half
month jump on the cruellest
April Fool's prank of all time but I
think that's less likely than there
being something that exists and before
I've seen knives out I'm going in for an
oil change
bio oil change I mean therapy which
therapy sessions they're like the oil
changes of Mental Health tell you the
truth I was kind of worried about this
year because once a year there's a movie
that everyone loves I just think he's
alright I was like where's that movie
this year I can't think of it and then I
saw knives out today I was like oh it's
knives out oh I mean now we're back on
track
now I feel like the world's turning on
its usual and normal access so
it's uploading right now let's see how
it goes my mom's upstairs playing beat
saber right now like she'll ask me like
can I come over and play beat saber
she's like weirdly addicted to beat
saber
I guess not weirdly this is a very fun
game but yeah she's just she likes
coming over and playing beats it's
always like yeah come on over play beat
saber I'm just checking emails and
YouTube comments and she's rocking beats
it but my mom is still playing beat
saber in the next room over and I have
it on Steam so there's a huge steam
community and the mod songs and they
basically make custom songs she's
playing beat Sabre - Rob Zombie's
dragula and it's amazing but you get mom
of the year just for that alone you get
more emotion out of the Mandalorian then
you do the CGI Lion King characters for
the animals
there's CGI Lion King movie set yeah
I made a snappy little Instagram post
about it also it's 6:00 in the morning
and I haven't slept probably cuz I'm
excited because it's Customer
Appreciation Day at Olympic carts and
comics the greatest comic book store of
all time so my friend and I are going to
that those texts it was like I think I'm
gonna pull an all-nighter so come over
earlier maybe I'll stop by the store and
get some surge on the way out really
live it up like work you know 20 again I
can't do all-nighters anymore but it
looks like my body said I'm going to so
there's that right guys my dogs feel
like hell yeah madness I tell you
regarding comics in Olympia or Lacey
they're like the same but they're not
and it has BestBuy had hold SD card for
the switch on sale for 20 bucks because
Black Friday is not like this weird for
our event anymore it's it trickles it
goes on for a couple weeks now so anyhow
got an SD card which happy about because
space goes pretty fast so I just read
that there was a patch four days ago
that fixes night trap for the PS Vita
and makes it beatable Hobson how the
time is cuff time to see if this is true
so when doing Survivor mode on night
trap it makes this be beep sound and I
forgot that those kinds of sounds freak
gifs yet I don't know why but they just
do so she's over here scared dangerous
comforting her keep your hair look at
these two little fraidy-cats
oh no this happened halfway through so
it might still be [ __ ] I really like
Sindel she came out today she's selling
Terminator wasn't really my fighting
style but Sindel and shank soon are
probably my favorites of the DLC so far
alright so sandals ending sucks like for
her character it's quite a retcon Sindel
fans are gonna be really pissed but she
plays well
[Music]
I was like hey gonna hang out with
friends at 9:00 a.m. so I need to get to
bed early so I went to bed at 11 I was
actually pretty tired woke up at 2:00
a.m.
have not been able to go back to sleep
since so I was like all right time
management I can film my review for the
irishman so that's what I'm about to do
it's a Kong put food in it it's totally
not an ass plug looks like you're poor
it is dead so I'm here with my friend
Adam the best friend and we're we were
talking about cuz Terminator 2 is on
sale for like seven bucks here and I was
talking about the new Terminator and I
told him what happened he didn't know
and he was like that's the worst thing
you can do that's also the most 2019
thing he did - he cracked me up so much
I had to tell you about it
alright we're gonna do a journal entry
because vanessa has been singing the
song drink it - you do look like the
cover of an alcoholic beverage that's
for sure so I got to do an entry on this
my friend and his wife they're cleaning
out all this stuff because they were
moving and downsizing a little bit they
were like hey I have this box of stuff
do you want it so a couple of Nintendo
Power magazines or at least a Super NES
guy that came with Nintendo power box
full of stuff I'll get to a Super
Nintendo it's got the yellowing that
happened and also there's a ps2 slim
that they gave me that I have in the
nerd room right now it's why you're not
seeing it here but then all these
Gameboy Advance
a box is Final Fantasy 4 Final Fantasy 6
Final Fantasy 1 and 2 Kingdom Hearts
final fantasy 5 probably should have had
those in order when I was doing this
video zelda 2 The Adventures of link
Donkey Kong Country 2 Fire Emblem the
Sacred Stones Legend of Zelda Minish Cap
Metroid Fusion
Golden Sun Mario vs. Donkey Kong Kirby
the amazing mirror he was just like here
you could have them it was even like if
you have the games to go with them
because I think I might have left them
at your house which he did
here's like I you can have the games too
so there they are completing box I was
like are you sure you know you can
e-mail this stuff but Adam I'm letting
you know right now if you come to me and
you're like I think I may have made a
mistake I'm not gonna look a gift horse
in the mouth and be like I completely
understand in the meantime I'll hold on
to him for you
because I'm just gonna go ahead and
appreciate the [ __ ] out of this because
thank you very much for watching I
really do appreciate it not gonna keep
you too much with the outro as I know
you're on YouTube which means there's a
lot to watch out there so I'll let you
go but from me to you thank you very
much I do appreciate you watching
another journal entry I make them for
you as well as myself we're all having
fun looking back at a month lived and
now transition with danger with this
true love the ball you do not like this
done
[Music]
you